good evening I am Donna LeMond and
you're watching piu news the most
trusted news source on the internet I
don't have the mark I don't have the
chair I don't have the green screen the
first news I mean the first news comes
from Johnny D Johnny D which I made a
video on a few months ago and he is now
suffering from Phenom II upon Omiya I
don't really know how it's pronounced
pneumoniae it's a lung bacteria I think
I shouldn't even talk about it cuz I
don't know what it is but it's bad okay
it's bad and he needs our help
I tweet about this and Johnny D's wife
made a video explaining the situation
everybody my name is Helen I am Johnny
D's wife she talks about how Johnny D
started the channel from her gifting him
the karaoke set that included all the
songs he talks about how my video really
have to his channel a lot and he was
very happy about that
but as you probably know he got scammed
twice and he never got any of that money
which sucks I feel bad for for Johnny
and his situation and of course I want
to help as much as I can a lot of people
said this was fake so they uploaded
another video where you can clearly see
Johnny's in critical condition voltage
thank you can thankfully my wife's
daughter and they being the last day I
passed out at the hole I couldn't even
get to my cell phone call 91 1 I tweeted
the GoFundMe page that they link to
which is helping covering the the cost
for the medical bills I want to be able
to help as much as I can obviously I
want to be cautious about the situation
a lot of
criticizing me for not sharing this more
and stuff like that I just don't want
the money to end up in the wrong persons
hands since that technically has
happened twice already it is a lot of
money we're talking about here it's
already five thousand dollars being
donated and you should definitely happen
I want people to help but I also want to
be cautious and make sure that at least
this amount of money gets to Johnny D
make sure it does get covered by his
bills before applying more and then
risking the chance and me giving this a
shout out and that it will get lost
again that would just be the worst thing
that could happen and I want to try to
be somewhat responsible and hope that
afforded that not to have my watch on I
need to recover as best as possible
that's that's that's what I want more
than anything but just want to be a bit
cautious before sending more people into
house nevertheless I hope Johnny
recovers as soon as possible so we can
have him back making his amazing karaoke
videos that's all we want Johnny D if
you're watching keep hanging in there
the bros got your back boy
I am Don Lemon and I'm not supposed to
get my own personal feedback criticism
on the new champion news but this story
just makes me angry how can the media
keep attacking PewDiePie he hasn't even
done anything what is up Peter pine the
troubling content of YouTube's biggest
star childish offensive and immensely
popular the YouTube star whose real name
is Felix Kjellberg continues to command
a huge audience but what is he really
saying nah that's not there that's not
the tagline I remember reading here's
what the original headline said childish
bigoted and immensely popular the
YouTube star
what you changed date you changed attack
it's like can we call him a bigot let's
just not do that maybe we shouldn't call
him bigoted because then that it seems
like we're just a bunch of kids throwing
words and names around this article to
summarize it sort of insinuates that me
creating a book club is somehow a bad
that people should pay more attention to
what I'm doing online because who knows
what he's gonna do next
next month he might tell them to read
mine Kampf Oh a lot of people on Twitter
were really mad about this article and I
appreciate people standing up for me but
personally I'm not mad I'm also not
ignoring the fact that they they did say
some nice things in the article for
example here they say that Felix is
funny intelligent and innovative and
highly charismatic which of course all
of this I am he is but also being called
a narcissist a bigot and potential all
right
i I'm not mad okay I know it might be
confusing for some people I never
technically labeled myself towards any
political what's it called the group or
opinion I just personally don't see
myself aligning perfectly with anyone or
anything and really at the end of it I
don't care I genuinely just don't care I
talk a lot about social politics on this
channel I criticize it and I make fun of
it a lot because my channel was attacked
by it I don't see this article as an
attack on me despite a lot of people
thinking that it is and getting a lot of
people angry I see it as a display of
fear I wasn't necessarily upset about it
and also I'm kind of used to this sort
of treatment by now
I think they know that I have influence
they know it might not be over their
generation but it is influence that is
stronger than theirs at least of the
next and I think there's a there's a
definite fear there but they're losing
control I feel like there's a bigger
picture to discuss here where the media
has created a landscape of social
politics where they've gone around
throwing labels at everything racist
bigoted sexist all right
like it's nothing because it's quick its
effective and it's powerful and it's a
great way to control people he may not
have called me all trite in the article
but so desperately wanting to call me
all right to call him an alright
agitator would perhaps be unfair as he
has never publicly identified with a
proto fascist movement but he shares
much of their culture and amplifies it
across the world just because other
people don't share the exact same
opinions as the media does not mean that
everyone else is an alt right this
landscape of
constantly throwing around labels and
twisting the meaning of them and
changing to fit into this obscure shape
it's just nonsensical it's laughable
which is why I enjoy criticizing it on
this channel and which is why I enjoy
humoring it because it's just so bizarre
Oh what was said was a joke doesn't
matter we can call him this Oh what was
said was taken out of context doesn't
matter we can call him this does that
mean I completely agree with political
groups that are popular online for not
agreeing with this idea
no come on media I don't want to keep
fighting with you why what do I gotta do
if you actually watch my videos I think
you'd find that it's not that bad all
right we're just reading books here all
right and reading books is a good thing
huh don't be so bigoted Brad is now
going to say though whether Brad tell us
about the weather smug I say the weather
sounds pretty smug right now I forgot
the most important news as is coming out
on all consoles that's right a Nintendo
Gameboy Nintendo advanced and the Xbox
which check it out guys ass full version
you definitely don't want to miss this
for more info link in the description
have I told you by my chair let's just
get this last story out of the way I
almost don't want to talk about it but
at the same time then it might seem like
I don't care or that I don't think it's
important as you probably heard there
was a shooter at the YouTube headquarter
in San Bruno a shooter entered with a
handgun and shot three people and then
itself and thank God no one got killed
except the shooter of course at least
that's what I know I'm not sure what
it's the situation of the victims so far
although the ones that got hurt I don't
want this to be another video where
someone talks about the situation but
nothing really gets said I've seen so
many of those I know people mean well
and I know it's hard to discuss these
situations but I think it would be
ignorant of me to ignore the fact that I
think it would be ignorant or or
cowardice for me to ignore the fact that
the the shooter did acknowledge that the
shooter did speak about the monetization
and that frustration and it hasn't been
confirmed if that was the reason behind
the shooting but it's it's out there I
saw on the website of the shooter there
was promoting some videos of their
monetization rants and saying that their
videos were being censored or less views
or something like that and thank God
none of my videos were there Jesus
Christ YouTube say you've had a rough
year man I for anyone that was involved
in this horrible incident I'm just so
sorry you had to go through something
like this
I can only my I can imagine what that's
like and to everyone that works at
YouTube I I really sympathize for having
to go to work and with at least some bit
of fear now this is awful the situation
just to put it plain is simply it's just
bad for everyone and I don't want it to
seem like I'm pointing fingers I don't
think this whole this situation is
anyone's direct fault and whether it's
YouTube or the community but I think
it's important to at least acknowledge
the fact that there is a huge division
between the creators and and the website
and I think there's been a very
frustrating year for everyone involved
where all the changes that came with the
apocalypse led to so much confusion and
anger and I would never have guessed it
would have led to something so horrible
and despicable like this but a lot of
time with the these situations what I do
is I just go on Twitter and when things
go wrong with YouTube I just go on
Twitter because it's a good way to
relieve stress or I'll make some sort of
YouTube brand and discuss it in a
humorous way to sort of rant about it
because if it relieves that stress and I
I've talked about this before but I know
from the outside it might be hard to
understand because YouTube comes with so
many amazing perks it's really like made
my life so much better than I could ever
imagine
it's given me my dream job and all these
things possible but it is so mentally
Polling sometimes I sort of forced
myself over the years to distance myself
from YouTube because it's it's just too
stressful otherwise and I've talked to a
lot of different credit creators over
the years and I think most of them
admits to at least some point have gone
through a really tough mental period
it's not always as simple as it may seem
and I I really think most people on
YouTube has gone through that at some
point whether they care to admit it or
not and I can only imagine that if you
have that stress and anger built up over
a long time and you're a [ __ ] crazy
person then that's what creates these
sort of insane scenarios and obviously I
don't know if that's necessarily what
happened but I'm just speculating here
but if that is the case I think it's
really important that more than ever
that we really connect YouTube and the
creators more than we have I think
YouTube is definitely working on that
and should just keep doing that and but
I also think we as creators can do a
better job at communicating with YouTube
as well and not always just rant and
talk about it in a stupid way like I've
been doing for example a lot of times I
have been trying to engage more with
YouTube in a more serious way to
actually fix a lot of the issues because
we have we it's it's a it's a crisis
situation and and I think this shows
that I don't want to see them all like
kumbaya we should all just get together
and hold hands kind of moments but I do
think at times like this it's just more
important than ever just to come
together that's it that's all I have to
say about it
it just sucks hey I don't know what else
to say thanks for watching PU news I am
Don Lemon it's been my pleasure
hopefully next week won't be so horrible
this video will definitely have garbage
ads on it so I do appreciate if you want
to support the show by buying a Pew news
month link is in the description have a
great one and I'll see you next time I
am Don Lemon everybody
[Music]
I'm not editing anything in here just
leave